Les conservateurs choisissent leur chef
en fin de semaine.
La manière de voter est vraiment complexe
Laissez -moi vous expliquer.
Les 13 candidats conservateurs doivent
amasser des points.
Chaque circonscription vaut 100 points.
Il y a 338 circonscriptions.
Donc, un total de 33 800 points.
Toutes les circonscriptions ont le
même poids,
peu importe le nombre de membres qui y vivent.
Pour l'instant, c'est simple mais ça se complique un peu.
Ça, c'est le bulletin de vote qu'ont reçu les
259 000 membres du parti.
C'est à partir de ce  qui sera sur ces bulletins que les points seront distribués
Les membres doivent classer en ordre de préférence
leurs 10 candidats favoris.
Le parti va tout d'abord calculer les premiers choix.
Dans chaque circonscription, l'appui obtenu sera transféré en points.
Par exemple, 30% des votes, ça vaut 30 points.
Pour gagner, il faut q'un candidat accumule la moitié des points disponibles.
Donc au moins 16 900 points.
Dans cette course, des candidats il y en a beaucoup.
Donc il faudra probablement plusieurs tours avant de trouver un gagnant.
Certains croient que 8 ou même 10 tours seront nécessaires.
C'est difficile à prédire.
À chaque tour, le candidat qui aura la moins bonne performance sera éliminé.
Les points qu'avait obtenu ce candidat seront redistribués.
Ce sont les candidats qui avaient été inscrits comme deuxième choix
par les membres dont le candidat est maintenant hors-circuit,
qui vont obtenir ces points.
On continue comme ça, tour après tour,
jusqu'à ce qu'un candidat soit élu chef.
Vous suivez toujours?
Avec ce système de vote,
il y a deux éléments clés.
L'importance d'avoir des appuis partout au pays,
même dans les régions qui sont moins conservatrices
Parce que chaque circonscription compte
et a un poids égal.
Mais il faut aussi être perçu par les membres comme un bon deuxième ou troisième choix.
Donc comme une personne qui est rassembleuse.
Des facteurs qui pourraient brouiller les cartes
et créer la surprise.